une scène qui rappelle le début de la
pandémie l'antenne des dizaines de
milliers de travailleurs fui les grandes
villes confiné cet homme travaillait
dans une usine à delhi sans emploi
argent et nourriture il retourne dans
son village
un voyage d'une douzaine d'heures les
boutiques sont fermées au marché de
l'eau cno une initiative des commerçants
ils ont peur ils ont choisi de tout
fermer pour quatre jours explique cette
vendeuse de tabac il n'en pouvait plus
d'attendre après le gouvernement le
virus se répand comme le vent dit elle
j'ai peur mais je dois continuer de
travailler
cet hôpital nous ne traite que des
patients contaminés par le virus jusqu'à
500 lits sont disponibles cet
amphithéâtre a été converti en salle de
surveillance des caméras ont été
installées pour minimiser les
interactions entre le personnel et les
patients
officiellement le nombre d'infections
quotidienne a plus que quintuplé en un
mois en inde
mais la réalité serait bien pire les
dessins hindous sont couverts de fleurs
puis brûlé conformément à leur religion
des bûcher funéraire supplémentaires ont
été aménagés à look no ce qui me fait
qu'alimenter les rumeurs sur le bilan
réel de la pandémie en inde
le relâchement des mesures sanitaires
les rassemblements des fêtes comme au
lit la pénurie de vaccins sont blâmés
pour cette deuxième vague tendance
inquiétante dans un pays où les deux
tiers de la population ont moins de 35
ans les patients infectés sont plus
jeunes que l'on passé et dans les
hôpitaux indiens sont débordés cet
établissement songe même à prodiguer des
soins à domicile pour certains patients
nous pouvons leur fournir des bouteilles
d'oxygène explique cette responsable qui
doit travailler de la maison pour se
protéger inquiétude supplémentaire la
récente découverte de variants indien
qui se propage particulièrement dans les
villes les plus touchées de l'inde
mumbai et delhi le varia indien est
aussi appelé double mutants il serait
plus contagieux et plus résistants aux
anticorps donc peut-être au vaccin
on en sait peu sur ces risques réels
mais là il pourra devenir un incubateur
géant de covè 19 poules et les
confinements et couvre-feu ont été
imposées trop tard croit-elle le mal est
déjà fait
dans le sous continent indien qui se
croyait immunisées contre la pandémie il
y encore deux mois
l'inquiétude et le désespoir progresse
encore plus rapidement que la deuxième
vague
il sait philippe leblanc radio-canada
look no aux mains